[Música]
Hola Mi nombre es Ángela Gómez y aquí
comienza ella soy el programa feminista
de France 24 hoy nuestro tema es una
gran noticia Argentina publicó la
reglamentación de la ley de equidad de
género en los medios de comunicación que
busca una mayor igualdad de los Derechos
entre las personas sin importar su
identidad de género o su orientación
sexual la medida que fue aprobada en
2021 permitirá darle esa más voz y
responsabilidad a las mujeres en los
medios pero también a las personas trans
y no binarias Gabriel colchón de la
redacción de Franz 24 nos cuenta más en
su informe
cambiar la estructura machista y
patriarcal en los medios de comunicación
es el objetivo de la ley de equidad de
género que fue promulgada en Argentina
la ley Busca ampliar la participación de
las mujeres y personas trans y no
binarias en los servicios de
comunicación ahora los medios estatales
deberán cumplir con una cuota de 1% de
personas gnosis generó en sus equipos de
esta manera fija la obligatoriedad de
garantizar un cupo de no menor al 1%
para personas travestis transexuales
transgéneros e intersex en la totalidad
del personal de medios gestionados por
el estado según una encuesta realizada
en los medios de Buenos Aires las
mujeres y personas trans y no binarias
son más presentes en las ramas de mayor
precariedad y menos presentes en los
tipos de medios con mejores condiciones
laborales por ejemplo representan el
57,1% de los trabajadores de un ámbito
más precario al revés en televisión
donde las condiciones suelen ser mejores
solo representan el 30,2% del total
además menos mujeres acceden a puestos
de jefatura y casi un 30% de ellas
afirman tener un salario inferior a sus
colegas masculinos para el mismo trabajo
finalmente la ley Busca luchar contra la
violencia de género y promueve el uso
del lenguaje inclusivo de las salas de
lactancia y los centros de Cuidado
infantil en los servicios de
comunicación todas estas normas serán
obligatorias para los medios estatales y
son un incentivo para los medios
privados Ahora toca que tanto el estado
como los gremios sigan de cerca esta ley
para que se cumpla vamos a charlar sobre
este tema y sobre este cambio en
Argentina para ello invitamos a Micaela
polac ella es secretaria de géneros del
sindicato de prensa de Buenos Aires
Micaela bienvenida Gracias por estar en
ella soy muchas gracias a ustedes por la
entrevista
vamos a ver cómo cómo se desarrolla esta
noticia pero vamos a empezar por el
inicio en medios públicos se habla de al
menos un 1% de comunidad diversa que es
obligatoria dentro de las contrataciones
sin embargo es una cifra realmente baja
es una cifra simbólica porque ese 1%
Bueno siempre son un piso los cupos no
de ahí esperamos partir hacia más arriba
de todos modos hay dos leyes ahí que
están en conjunto digamos que son por un
lado la de cupo laboral travesti trans
que ustedes refieren y la equidad en los
medios es otra que tienen mucho que ver
y que ahora vamos a desarrollar ese uno
por ciento es porque tenemos en la
Argentina una expectativa de vida de las
personas travesti trans que no supera
los 35 años
esto es el dato más crudo de una
realidad que tiene que ver con que
es una población expulsada de sus
hogares Generalmente a una edad muy
temprana y que no tiene a partir de
entonces
determinados cuidados de salud y no
tiene los estudios que se requieren para
poder ingresar en trabajos formales en
general por eso es que la expectativa no
es tan alta la del cupo Y sí se espera a
partir de eso que empiece a crecer ahora
decíamos que hay otra ley que es la de
equidad de género en los medios salieron
más o menos al mismo tiempo la de cupo
laboral travesti trans se reglamentó
enseguida Y a esta equidad de género en
los medios le tardó un poco más bastante
más fueron un par de años que demoraron
en la reglamentación pero que tienen que
ver porque la equidad de lo que habla a
diferencia
de lo que podríamos entender como
igualdad o paridad de género que sería
una foto la foto de la cantidad de
mujeres y diversidades y la cantidad de
varones por ejemplo la equidad lo que
plantea es una película no es cómo se
llega a ese número final Y entonces es
donde se relacionan estas dos leyes
porque la lo que necesitamos para que el
cupo laboral través sea mucho más alto
Es que la película empiece de otra
manera para ellos Micaela antes de
continuar Quisiera hacer una Claridad
para nuestra audiencia y es acerca de
estas cifras de expectativa de vida de
las ciudadanas trans
y tiene que ver con con que se realizó
una encuesta en el 2015 en la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos Y de
esa muestra que se tomó que tenía que
ver con homicidios la mayoría de
víctimas eran menores a 35 años lo digo
porque claro es importante ver que no
necesariamente esta tiene que ser la
expectativa de vida de las personas y y
ha sido una cifra confusa en general
Pero bueno pasando de eso quisiera
preguntarle sobre las sanciones de las
que se habla en esta reglamentación
porque leyendo un poco el texto se
hablaba de un llamado de atención Que
vuelvo a preguntarle es algo más
simbólico que otra cosa o cómo va a
verificarse el cumplimiento de esta
reglamentación
de la ley de equidad de género estamos
hablando claro
la ley de equidad de género sí plantea
la obligatoriedad como bien decías para
los medios públicos y el se supone que
el estado controla al propio estado Así
que las sanciones se tienen que de
determinar en algún momento lo cierto Es
que la reglamentación que tenemos desde
la semana pasada
implica un término de 90 días para que
el Ministerio de trabajo que es la
autoridad de aplicación que es quien va
a ejercer ese control sobre los medios
públicos en este caso bueno tenga un
tiempo para establecer Cuál va a ser el
registro de los medios que cumplen con
la ley de equidad entonces a partir de
ese registro es que va a empezar a
correr estas sanciones para los medios
públicos En caso que las hubieras y a la
vez un reconocimiento de los medios
privados que cumplan con la ley pero
para llegar a ese registro lo que se
está planteando es un debate público
entre
trabajadoras trabajadores y sociedad
civil universidades empresarios de las
cámaras de los medios en la Argentina
donde podamos llegar a un acuerdo
digamos y que el Ministerio tenga a
partir de eso una herramienta para poder
efectuar ese registro y que
efectivamente empiece a correr la ley
bueno Micaela esto es detrás de las
pantallas o detrás en las salas de
redacción de los diversos medios pero
quiero preguntarle como un cambio en las
planillas de los medios que esté más
enfocado en la diversidad como es el
objetivo de esta reglamentación podría
cambiar lo que los usuarios ven en sus
pantallas lo que leen en los periódicos
en los medios de comunicación digitales
etc etc
sí sabemos que los medios reproducen una
cultura pero también la producen que un
montón de los estereotipos que surgen de
las pantallas sobre todo pero también de
las radios y en menor parte tal vez de
la prensa escrita pero que si vemos
quienes firman las notas en prensa
escrita estas leyes no son de ese ámbito
pero también lo resaltamos en general
los roles que tenemos las mujeres y
diversidades en los medios no son los
mismos que los de los varones hay mucho
estereotipo al respecto somos las
mujeres las que hablamos del clima del
tránsito de espectáculos de chimentos
pero en general no somos las que
hablamos de economía de política de
estadística de ciencia bueno todo eso es
algo que pretendemos cambiar con esta
película de la equidad de tratar de
enfocarnos en Cuáles son los contenidos
que producimos porque estamos seguras a
la vez también de a quienes
entrevistamos No porque si siempre que
vamos a hablar de economía llamamos a
varones nosotras sabemos incluso las que
estamos detrás de cámara que eso es una
tendencia que podemos revertir Y si una
niña escucha a una mujer hablando de
economía es muy probable que en algún
momento de su vida piense que es posible
aunque sea aunque no le guste digo pero
que sepa que es posible que ella también
hable y se interese por la economía
Entonces los estereotipos que se
reproducen en los medios tenemos que
intentar
revertirlos con con buenos ejemplos
precisamente precisamente los casos de
la representación que vemos por ejemplo
en televisión que es el medio en el que
ustedes y yo estamos comunicándonos no
es normalmente un lugar de diversidad y
esto no solamente pasa en Argentina
seguimos muy acostumbrados a unos
personajes que son caucasicos que son
muy heteronormativos que son delgados
que la mayoría de figuras aspiracionales
no no concuerdan con la realidad de la
gente de a pie que está muy lejos de la
perfección y el maquillaje que ofrecen
medios como como la televisión o las
transmisiones digitales Usted cree que
este cambio podría ser factible de aquí
Algunos años al final Pues los medios
están transformando
exacto y creemos que la sociedad se
empieza a transformar de alguna manera
que es también nuestra responsabilidad
cuando producimos contenidos
audiovisuales que eso suceda y sobre
todo empezar desde el principio desde el
sindicato al que pertenezco el ciproba
que es el sindicato de prensa de Buenos
Aires por ejemplo hemos firmado un
convenio con el mocha Celis que es un
bachillerato travesti trans que les
vamos a llevar la la vida de los medios
a las a las aulas para que esas personas
puedan conocer esta opción que tienen en
la vida digamos que haya otras opciones
que no terminen siempre vos hablabas de
asesinatos antes pero no es no es solo
la muerte temprana relativa al asesinato
sino a la a los cuidados a la aceptación
del estado en los sistemas de salud de
esas personas diversas que
al probablemente
puedan ir a un hospital pero depende de
cómo las traten van a volver o no a ese
hospital entonces tiene mucho que ver
con toda esa película de la que
hablábamos Cómo se llega a una pantalla
por ejemplo digamos sería el final o una
de las metas que tenemos en estas vidas
de personas diversas que no acceden hoy
a los medios de comunicación Pero porque
no acceden antes a muchas otras
oportunidades muy bien ya nos estamos
quedando sin tiempo y mi última pregunta
que podría parecerle obvio a usted pero
que es bueno recalcarla para los
televidentes es porque este es un paso
importante en una lucha de derechos
humanos y por la diversidad
bueno claramente la igualdad de
oportunidades es una un derecho humano
el derecho a un trabajo digno ahí
Tenemos un montón de batallas que
estamos dando mujeres y diversidades en
los medios de comunicación y claramente
este hito es importante y es en realidad
también un Punto de partida que sabemos
que vamos a tener que defender como
trabajadoras y trabajadores en
sindicatos para que se cumplan porque
tenemos muy buenas leyes en la Argentina
Pero la realidad es que necesitamos
exigir su cumplimiento muchas veces
Bueno ahora el paso que sigue es la
fiscalización de esa reglamentación que
ha sido aprobada Muchísimas gracias a
usted en Micaela pola secretaría de
géneros del sindicato de ciprueba
gracias a usted
muchas gracias a ustedes es un gusto
además haber estado con nuestros
televidentes nos vemos Próximamente en
France 24 y por supuesto en ellas hoy
[Música]